[Musique]
salut beauté
j'ai un peu de mal à me dire que le sac
à [ __ ] couche en face de moi et que le
meilleur fils de toute la brigade
je suis mort cette fois ci sur les gars
et monsieur alors on se réveille et tu
peux me vois tu souhaites tu peux me
voir c'est quoi ça je suis rapide se
valent jovial jovial tout plein d'amour
et de calembours on oublie tous ces
soucis on sourit à la vie oui on va se
marrer paris suit un ami imaginaire
je suis l'ami imaginaire ténue
avec moi elle accuse adorable de toutes
les petites filles
[Musique]
une seule puisse m'aider à la sauver
enfin une super équipe
la vraie question c'est plutôt et anton
jour de chance
oups j'ai fait propos tu es vraiment
vraiment nu comme conducteur pas
d'accord
regarde les bouchons qu'on a évité
joyeux noël